parce que nos vies se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro depuis le mois
de septembre pour un service aux
particuliers de la communauté
d'agglomération accueil à l'ambassadeur
de l'efficacité énergétique pour
accompagner les ménages précaires dans
la rénovation lancée par la fédération
française de randonnée les randos nec se
multiplient les amoureux de la marche en
profite pour ramasser les déchets qui
jonchent les sentiers à la fin du mois
de novembre
saint quentin en yvelines et
l'association terra cités ont réalisé un
état des lieux de l'agriculture sur
l'agglomération
il ya tout juste un an le point services
aux particuliers de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines signé un
partenariat avec erdf pour lutter contre
la précarité énergétique dans les
ménages les plus précaires de
l'agglomération ce partenariat a permis
la création d'un poste d'ambassadeur de
l'efficacité énergétique
il a commencé il ya quelques mois nous
l'avons rencontré lors d'une permanence
sur trappe
williams elle pour les images vounet
pour habiter mieux ce sens ferhat kessas
est propriétaire sur trappe depuis un an
son logement connaît des soucis
d'humidité il souhaite le rénover
accueilli par le directeur du point
services aux particuliers il est mis en
relation avec l'ambassadeur de l'énergie
rec
c'est un soutien oui il vient compléter
en fait le dispositif pôle énergie néo
pro services aux particuliers vraiment
tout simplement donc il a été rattaché
au pôle énergie l'ambassadeur de
l'efficacité énergétique qui connaît
aussi bien le programme habiter mieux
que les problématiques d'un payé
puisqu'il peut être aussi amené à
rencontrer des habitants et des
propriétaires occupants qui du coup sont
pas éligibles au programme habiter mieux
mais qui rencontrent tout même des
problématiques d'impayés d'électricité
ou de gaz
il ya tout un tas de travaux ça peut
être notre en intérieur comme en
extérieur donc tout ce qui est
l'isolation par exemple l'isolation des
murs isolation de la toiture nous qui
rapporte en général beaucoup guirec de
la porte et ambassadeur de l'efficacité
énergétique depuis le mois de février
formé par l' agence locale de l'énergie
du climat il reçoit les propriétaires
pour les renseigner sur les critères du
programme habiter mieux porté par l'
agence nationale de l'habitat ou comment
préparer leur dossier
il peut aussi les conseillers sur les
matériaux les mieux adaptés à leur
situation
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont
éligibles donc qui regroupe vraiment
tous les critères pour bénéficier des
aides du programme habiter mieux mais
qui sont pas au courant donc qu'ils vont
faire leurs travaux de leur côté sans
pour autant bénéficier des aides
auxquelles ils ont tout à fait le droit
oui c'est vrai qu'il faut monter le
dossier des fois ça peut prendre du
temps mais à côté les aides qui apporte
habiter mieux sont pas négligeables
il ya quelques points pour bénéficier de
ces aides
être propriétaire il faut que
l'appartement ou la maison et plus de 15
ans que ce soit des rénovations basé sur
les l'énergie le gaz enfin l'énergie en
globalité c'est obligatoirement fait par
une entreprise agréée grenelle de
l'environnement il ne faut pas avoir eu
de prêt à taux zéro et il faut que ça
atteint 25% de rénovation énergétique
depuis sa prise de poste direct de la
porte a rencontré une quinzaine de
familles saint-quentinoise sept d'entre
elles sont éligibles au programme
habiter mieux leurs dossiers sont en
cours d'évaluation
l'ambassadeur de l'efficacité
énergétique et donc présent au psp sur
trappe mais aussi au centre social de
magny les hameaux
si vous voulez vous renseigner en amont
sur la rénovation énergétique des sites
internet sont consultables comme celui
du gouvernement
ou celui de l'anah sur le programme
habiter mieux
la fédération française de randonnée
yvelines lance une opération appelée à
devenir annuel la rando net
le but est d'alerter le public sur la
propreté des balades de la région le 26
novembre dernier ce sont les randonneurs
élan courtois qui sont partis ramasser
des déchets qui jalonnent les chemins un
sujet de fanny bourdillon sur des images
de camille lambert alliés propreté et
randonnées c'est l'objectif de la rando
net toute nouvelle randonnée de 12 km
menée par l'association loisirs et
sports d'elancourt
nous avons la chance sur elle en cours à
proximité des encours d'avoir des lieux
quand on parcourt les sentiers des vieux
chemin est replongé dans un milieu rural
est bon on se fait en quelque sorte que
le milieu urbain si vous voulez ne
pollue pas le milieu dans lequel on a
plaisir à se déplacer
munis de sacs et de gants la trentaine
de participants s'élancent sur les
chemins balisés de la ville par les
cochons canettes mégots et boîtes de
conserve les sacs se remplissent vite
mais chez ces randonneurs élan pour toi
on n'a pas attendu cette opération
spéciale pour prendre soin de
l'environnement en général dans toutes
nos randonnées il ya toujours des gens
pour ramasser quelque chose qui traîne
de ses naturel mourir quand j'étais
sollicité j'ai dit oui tout de suite
parce que toute façon ça va rentrer dans
les habitudes des bords d'honneur de
garder la nature propre et donc voila
quoi comme on fait partie de la
fédération française de randonnée qu'on
n'a pas hésité lors de cette sortie les
randonneurs ont rempli 23 sacs près de
400 litres de déchets ont été ramassés
prochaine randonnée à elancourt en avril
la cap 21 qui s'est tenue au bourget du
30 novembre au 11 décembre a donné des
idées aux défenseurs de la nature et de
l'environnement
avec l'accord et l'accompagnement de
l'office national des forêts
l'association de sauvegarde des étangs
de la minière a planté quelques 200
jeunes armes pour reboiser un peu cette
zone anciennement touristique aux étangs
de la millière la nature continue de
reprendre ses droits
mais parfois elle a besoin d'un peu dead
l'association de sauvegarde des étangs
de la minière a donc sorti pire chez
piquer notre rôle c'est de protéger la
forêt de la minière et de faire en sorte
qu'elle quelle soit valorisée donc cet
espace qui est ténue depuis l'année
dernière qui était abandonné depuis une
bonne dizaine d'années va revivre
on espère grâce à nous et grâce aux
plans qui vont qui vont pousser dans les
prochaines années
j'avais par l'office national des forêts
les étangs de la minière accueillait une
base nautique dans les années 60 la
forêt d'andaine avant plein de
naturalisation l'intervention humaine
est exceptionnel faisant de la minière
disons que c'est à l'avancement de
des opérations de renouvellement des
peuplements eux
en règle générale on essaye d'avoir de
la régénération naturelle de fer par la
matière naturelle que puis que peut nous
donner la forêt c'est 90% des
régénérations des renouvellements des
peuplements il n'ya que franco d'échecs
où on
on envisage de replanter lors de cette
opération ce sont 150 chaînes 25 charme
et 25 points qui ont été plantés
il ne reste plus qu'à laisser le temps
faire son travail
la communauté d'agglomération et
l'association terre et cités ont
présenté un diagnostic de l'agriculture
locale sur saint quentin en yvelines un
état des lieux a été réalisé pour
identifier les conditions de
développement des filières agricoles de
proximité
un reportage de fanny bourdillon et
florane parfait certains les connaissent
bien d'autres les découvre les jardins
de la verrière font partie des milles 35
hectares cultivés de saint quentin en
yvelines le mois dernier l'agglomération
et l'association terre et cités ont
emmené les acteurs locaux et associatifs
dont plusieurs lieux de culture afin
d'illustrer le potentiel agricole du
territoire et ses bénéfices pour les
habitants il ya une multitude
d'associations qui font ce travail sur
l'agriculture urbaine avec des petits
bacs des petits potagers etc mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est vraiment de
sensibiliser les populations à une
alimentation de meilleure qualité et
locales et ensuite petit à petit les
habitants en viennent à consommer des
produits locaux
la produit à plus grande échelle sur les
exploitations du territoire des données
établies à la suite d'une étude menée
entre 2014 et 2015 conjointement par
l'agglomération et l'association
à la veille de l'agrandissement du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
une réalité qui doit être prise en
compte on s'est aussi rendu compte que
les exploitants étaient prêts à aller
vers des diversifications
alors peut-être pas leur génération mais
la génération suivante à condition
qu'ils soient que la fonctionnalité des
exploitations agricoles soit préservé
voire peut-être même amélioré au 1er
janvier 2016 les surfaces agricoles vont
doubler et dépasser les 2400 hectares
enfin d'ici 2022 il faudra définir un
projet pour la zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière du
plateau de saclay elle comprend une
partie de la commune de guyancourt
à l'issue des fêtes de fin d'année on
range dans les cartons de guirlandes et
décorations mais se pose souvent la
question du sapin où peut-on le déposer
peut-on le jeter n'importe où quelques
réponses
il trône peut être encore chez vous
après les fêtes de fin d'année il faut
le jeter et on ne peut le faire
n'importe comment
en le laissant dans la rue vous vous
exposez à une amende de 150 euros
même sanction pour les dépôts en forêt
en cause l'acidité du bois pour éviter
des sapins abandonné n'importe où des
communes multiplie les points de
collecte à voisins le bretonneux cette
fois encore on collectera dans neuf
lieux les rois de la forêt l'an dernier
800 30 sapins ont été broyés avant
d'être déposé dans plusieurs points de
la ville notamment à l'espace de coville
ou à la mairie
le paillage est une technique pour
éviter le recours aux produits
désherbants d'une part limiter
l'évaporation d'eau vous allez me dire
qu'en période hivernale
bon on a peut-être un peu moins besoin
mais c'est vrai que le broyard s en
place assez longtemps jusqu'au printemps
et deuxième chose ça sert empêcher la
pousse des mauvaises herbes
ce qui empêche le désherbage chimique on
limite mais le plus possible mais aussi
le désherbage à la main donc plus on
paye nos massifs - on à revenir dessus
pour l'entretien la commune de magny les
hameaux a décidé à partir du mois de
janvier de faire elle aussi ses propres
récoltes de sapins là aussi les arbres
seront broyés pour faire du paillage un
moyen pour la commune de magny de
continuer sa chasse aux produits
phytosanitaires
on va avoir trois points de collecte où
les gens on propose aux habitants de
déposez les sapins dans des bennes
qui et où la sécurité sera assurée par
le personnel du service technique
on souhaite les récupérer pour les
valoriser
ce qu'on demande aux habitants c'est de
retirer les guirlandes les boules les
emballages voilà qu'on est vraiment que
du bois de manière à pouvoir retraiter
ses sapins le plus simplement possible
si vous ratez les dates de ramassage de
votre commune vous pouvez toujours vous
rendre en déchetterie une benne dévié
aux végétaux est toujours présente pour
les sapins floqués pas de recyclage la
benne concernés sera celle du
tout-venant avant incinération
comme chaque mois quelques rendez-vous
ou bonne idée à noter le dimanche 20
décembre le collectif alternative à
saint quentin en yvelines propose des
ateliers poste comme 21
c'est l'occasion de faire le bilan des
avancées ou du futur
si vous n'avez pas encore terminé vos
préparatifs de noël
l'ademe vous donne quelques idées pour
les cadeaux la déco ou encore des éco
gestes pour que vous faites de noël soit
placée sous le signe de l'écologie
si vous voulez apprendre à faire votre
propre paillage le parc naturel de
chevreuse propose un atelier le 17
janvier au château de la madeleine
voilà équilibre s'est terminée en cette
période de noël je vous souhaite de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année et pensez à
faire un geste pour l'environnement
[Musique]